and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i
work for you and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing for you andrew
cuomo resigns as new york governor
following several claims of sexual
harassment
but his resignation doesn't go into
effect for two weeks
the news comes one week after the new
york attorney general claimed cuomo
sexually harassed
11 women including staffers and others
who did not work for his administration
during a press conference on tuesday
andrew reaffirmed his belief that the
accusations against him were unfounded
and called the situation politically
motivated
now you know me
i'm a new yorker born and bred
i am a fighter and my instinct
is to fight through this controversy
because i truly believe it is
politically motivated
i believe it is unfair and it is
untruthful and i believe
it it demonizes behavior
that is unsustainable for society
following the news of his resignation
celebs spoke out including cynthia nixon
who ran against him for office
she tweeted quote this is a good day for
new york
this is the start of accountability but
more needs to be done to keep women safe
that means prosecuting cuomo to the full
extent of the law
and it means moving forward with
impeachment to bar him from running for
statewide office ever
again nyc mayor bill de blasio said
quote
make no mistake this is the result of
survivors bravely telling their stories
it was past time for andrew cuomo to
resign and it's for the good of all new
york
and meghan mccain also tweeted saying in
part quote
cuomo was not only a serial abuser but
killed 15 000 elderly victims in nursing
homes
due to negligence he made 5 million
profiting from a book deal
all while the media called themselves
homosexuals
and ignored his criminal behavior of
course homosexuals is a term given to
fans of both andrew and his brother
cnn anchor chris cuomo we spoke to
chris's daughter and wife about that
just last year what do you make of all
of this talk bell about your uncle and
your dad
it's kind of weird to open tick tock up
and see people calling my family members
hot
like that's a weird experience um
i mean it's they can be sometimes
they're funny things you know people do
impersonations
and yeah they make jokes out of it and
it's like okay i'll acknowledge those
like how many times like
you know gonna acknowledge like girls my
friend age being like
oh my god chris at the start of the
coven 19 pandemic andrew was a regular
guest on chris's cnn show
cuomo primetime after allegations
surfaced about andrew chris said he
would not cover the news on his
broadcast
he also apologized for getting involved
by serving as a consultant to his
brother amid his sexual harassment
scandal